[Music]
hey here's the thing if you provide
service
uh to one person you're gonna make
one
dollar or one amount of money if you
precise provide service to millions of
people you're gonna make millions of
dollars
and you didn't steal any of it evil rich
people is a bunch of crap
it's a lie
here's an example my friend mark cuban
and
i can actually dial mark's phone number
and he actually will answer we have very
short conversations because he and i are
just alike we don't talk on the phone
hey what see
that's it yeah yeah done no i email him
sometimes and he emails me back no yep
or maybe later we'll talk later or
something you know that kind of stuff so
big big deep in in-depth relationship
but uh um
but he has uh to to his credit
billionaire this from uh this on npr oh
god
a billionaire investor and dallas
mavericks owner mark cuban has launched
an online pharmacy for generic drugs
that promises steep discounts over
traditional distributors the mark cuban
cost plus drug company announced opening
its online pharmacy wednesday the
pharmacy says it will bypass the
healthcare industry middlemen and help
consumers avoid high drug prices by
charging manufacturers prices
plus a flat
15
markup and pharmacist fee
all drugs are priced at cost plus 15
percent
sign up and share your thoughts and
experiences with us cuban tweeted last
week
cuban's pharmacy says it will negotiate
drug prices directly with manufacturers
to lower its costs for consumers one
drug for diabetes patients sells for
three dollars and ninety cents for a
30-day supply compared for retail at
twenty dollars a 30 count of um i can't
pronounce it which is used to treat
leukemia and other cancers goes for as
low as 17 and 10 cents at cuban's
pharmacy compared to 2
500
instead of 17
at other pharmacies now cuban's going to
make another billion doing this
and he will have helped millions of
millions of people
get drugs for 17 dollars instead of 2
500.
what's evil about this so
you literally have a billionaire here
that that by looking at this article
looks like he is attempting to provide a
public good somebody who says i've got
the money and resources i'm sick of
people i know who have lesser
less less economic uh buying power than
i do
not being able to afford their drug i'm
solving this problem and i'm gonna make
a lot of money why why is that i don't
understand the opposing force there
there it's it's um if i'm happy you
can't be because you took up because i
took up all the happiness yeah it's like
there's a something like there's a game
like it's a fixed joy
yeah it's a fixed pie if you make a
bunch of money that means someone else
didn't that's not how money works
oh man rabbi lapin says money is more
like candles than cake
if you get a big slice of cake that
means someone else gets a smaller slice
no that's not how money works so it's
more like candles when you light a
candle your candle is not diminished and
you light another candle and you light
another candle and you light another
counter and then you got christmas eve
service oh huh
so this is mark cubans here's a here's
something that just happened just a few
minutes ago
um
i went and
did a
talk with a
guy who owns a couple of car dealerships
in kentucky and met with this team
around the tornado
right he was right on the tornado he
asked me to come up there talk about
crisis talk about stuff talk about
trauma talk about trauma how do we move
past this and his first time his group
got back together and as a part of that
conversation i was asking
individual people what are they what's
what's something that's real and
tangible that's going on in your life
right now somebody stood up and talked
about a problem with their home they
don't have a home yeah and
um they just bought a new home and then
a sale of their old home fell through it
was just a mess
and
this owner quietly said he called his
wife and said i'm gonna buy a house
today
and i he didn't elaborate further ended
up buying that house and said i'm gonna
find something good to do with this
house and thought i'll flip it whatever
then somebody in this and when the
tornadoes came through
he was able to provide housing for a
family that's been displaced and now has
the idea of i'm gonna keep this thing
and definitely i can just use this to
serve
because people need a place to stay
whether it's two months five months one
year and now i've got an opportunity to
help them and that's a 30-year game of
somebody who's been stewarding their
money taking care of their people he's
got a heart of a servant and now has the
resources to say i'm going to help you
and i'm going to help them i'm going to
serve my community and no one will ever
know this happened because he's not he's
not a billionaire mark cuban he's just
owns a couple of car dealerships in a
small community that just got wiped out
by tornadoes and he's able to help right
he didn't have to call the government
doesn't have to call any cert he's able
to help and the those stories go untold
day after day minute by minute all
across this country man
so the data
actually says
that when your
[ __ ] friend or family member says rich
people are evil
the data actually says that your friend
or relative is a [ __ ] but they're wrong
that's what the data says
it says that guy's a [ __ ] he's just
wrong
and he doesn't know what he's talking
about he has no first-hand knowledge he
has no data to back this up because the
actual data says that there are no more
evil people among rich people than there
are among poor people
turns out there's jerks that have money
and there's jerks that don't and there's
good people that have money and good
people that don't this is the ramsay
show